the introduction to bioinformatics
course is an introduction to the field
of bioinformatics or the intersection of
informatics and biology it speaks about
the opportunities that come with the
available big data and methods for its
analysis for research in industry
including healthcare agriculture
environmental sciences Public Health and
more biology is rapidly acquiring the
character of a data science billions of
data points on genes proteins and other
molecules are compiled in large files
and systematically studied analyzing
this data will lead to more knowledge
and understanding about living organisms
including human health
biotechnology crops and livestock this
course will give an overview of
bioinformatics for students biologists
and clinicians the influx of data
associated methodologies and data driven
research makes bioinformatics for Life
Sciences as prominent as the emergence
of computers for the tech industry the
course is divided into three sections
introduction to Big Data bioinformatics
bioinformatics and healthcare
transitional bioinformatics and all of
them can be completed in under two hours
of study the course will provide
important information terminology and
perspectives from experts in this
exciting field there are three sections
that can be completed in about 2 hours
of study with a quiz at the end
the course can be taken by anyone
without any special knowledge in related
fields after signing up and completing
your profile you'll be able to see your
progress and notice points you've earned
accumulate based on this activity you
can acquire certificates of completion
for this course as well as others on the
edu T bio info platform as an
introductory course you will also learn
about our project-based approach at
learning bioinformatics we take datasets
from high impact publications and
convert them into online learning
experiences each subsequent course you
take will have a practical application
that demonstrates how bioinformatics can
be used these projects will fall under
certain specializations such as oncology
neuroscience agro tech and others the
specializations provide domain
experience and explain basic
bioinformatics concepts related to that
subject as a result anyone starting on
this journey in bioinformatics can start
developing a project of their own by
seeing how experts analyze their data
and achieve research results you can
start developing a research question of
your own identify the appropriate type
of data you should be using and then
plan your analysis this introductory
course leads into multiple courses and
projects that can serve as a springboard
into the world of bioinformatics in
subsequent courses we will be using the
T bio info platform to process big
datasets this platform is built from
multi-omics integration and analysis of
structured data with advanced methods
such as machine learning and
mathematical modeling after you've set
up your account make sure to try out our
analytical platform you can do so by
filling out the form at server T bio
info this analytical platform will
provide hands-on experience for anyone
to apply the learn skills to interesting
datasets with color coded logical maps
explanation of methods detailed input
and output formats as well as
reproducible workflows this course
provides a broad overview but is
structured to offer significant depth
even for the experienced after
completing the short introduction you'll
be inspired to continue learning about
this exciting field of bioinformatics
this program has been tested in multiple
universities around the world and
reviewed by experts in the field of
bioinformatics we are excited that you
joined so let's start learning